[Music]
hello this is you welcome with Marcel
Arguello that's me I'm a comedian I'm
amazing and my guests are Priyanka wali
comedian / doctor and Lidia Popovich
comedian / bad [ __ ]
no disrespect Priyanka you're also a bad
[ __ ] dr. beverage doctor bad [ __ ] yeah
and this is Kachina she's new so she's
attached what's it like to be a woman in
comedy anybody want to jump off I mean
it's great to be a woman in comedy I
agree I think it's a better time than
ever I love it I have no problems with
it does it propose unique challenges
when you're by yourself and you're on
the road absolutely does it present
unique challenges when you're not alone
and with other people being another
woman or another man absolutely yeah and
I think you also have to take into
consideration like you two are both
significantly taller than I do think
about safety as a female comedian yeah
and so I definitely don't think about
safety yeah that you probably take for
granted but I yeah like I reminded take
you for granted I'm very aware that men
and women are frightened of me yeah
whereas I'm scared of everyone yeah yeah
I remember like going to open mics in
the beginning and being really stressed
out because of safeties three of us all
started in the Bay Area doing comedy
it's a unique little world I mean
there's a lot of creeps and weirdos
roaming around San Francisco and the San
Francisco comedy scene and and I'm not
just talking about the comedian's I
guess the periscope comedy scene has
changed a lot
I don't go back that much anymore and I
know the punch line is closing to move
and so I don't know how you guys feel
about that I mean it's interesting
because when I started in San Francisco
I didn't worry about going to open mics
I never worried about my safety until we
started traveling and traveling around
and then that's when I started worrying
about my safety but that is because of
what I look like in who I am and how I
carry myself I'm a very big personality
so I went out of my way to make sure
that people did not [ __ ] with me right
do you think San Francisco has changed
think that it's an incredibly wealthy
city now which means that there's sort
of this air of entitlement
yeah to absolutely everything yeah which
i think is making it more difficult for
people to laugh and to have fun I don't
know what it's done to safety because I
don't live there anymore yeah but I
don't feel like people like like to
laugh anymore yeah I definitely have
stuff to say about that because first of
all with Silicon Valley blowing up in
the Bay Area what you have now is an
influx of young engineers they tend to
be very emotionally unintelligent they
they have a lot of money too so you have
new audiences that have wealth to come
to these shows but they don't have life
experience a sense of humor yes like
they're not like that matures this stuff
they laugh at is really just weird stuff
yeah and I and I remember like as I
progressed how much the comedy would
change and it would get to the point
where like you would do well but you
wouldn't like feel good about it cuz
yeah like we're making this weird group
of people laugh about weird stuff so
yeah I created a word because people on
the left and the right are both like so
sensitive right now and the word is
offend Oh normative one word describes
people who are offended all the time by
words on behalf of other people no one
asked you to be offended and it applies
to so many different types of people and
I think that a lot of the tech bros
definitely fall into like they sometimes
are offended at the wrong time and it's
like dude what do you the most random
points at which to be offended yeah
they're weird yeah we hashtagged men are
weird so Lee and I why I should say I
just finished doing a tour for the woke
bully which is my album get it download
its treatment torment I don't even care
what is it torrent torrent is don't
torment format yeah you probably could
torment you first rate employment it and
so I did a tour and Lydia join me on
many of those dates Lydia I don't know
how your experience was but I had a
great time saved for a couple of dates
that were pretty brutal true I was
thinking about how in comedy because we
as insecure human individuals we focus
on the negative more
so then on the positive so it's like if
you have a really great show you're like
that was great and then you move on
pretty quickly and you forget it but
then you have a bad show and that stays
with you I mean it's it's like a spunk
that you can't wash off I had a couple
of those but I don't I don't know how
you felt cuz you're featuring doing 2025
minutes is pretty yeah I did a sweet
spot it is it's kind of hard I think you
told me once it's like it's kind of hard
not to crush in 20 minutes yeah like
it's if you don't then you should look
better at your act and look at your
timing and make better choices right
because like here are people that are
coming to see a headliner the headliner
has hand-selected you how can you not
right right yeah bad shows are
subjective I've definitely had sets
where we had a fire night but I ran way
long which is not another thing that I
like to do yeah I was also something I
don't like her to do either she was very
mad at rightly so yeah had a great set
but because I started off at or going
over which is something that you
shouldn't do in comedy always do your
time don't run the light be respectful
of the room especially if it's a place
you've never been before do you want to
work somewhere [ __ ] get it together but
that's money basically what I was
talking to myself about right and I
carried that but other people would've
been like I crushed she's overreacting
she's mad because I crushed Brae and I
think that's a big difference to young
women and to friends that are traveling
yeah yeah yeah there's two male comics
words like we're competitive but not
with each other in that way right right
she pushes me to be stronger you know I
want her to do the best that she's gonna
do if I do great she's gonna do great
right those shows where you do something
wrong or something doesn't land the way
that you wanted to can be just as
devastating as a show that was empty as
hell which we also had I think that's
one of the things that's holding us back
as females in comedy is that we feel
like there needs to be this perfect
situation in order for us to crush so I
used to open for a Felipe Esparza
there's a great comedian he has a great
podcast on all things comedy called
what's up full and he would point out
when men would want to come up and say
what's up to me and the girlfriend would
pull the dude like he would see them
physically restrain like their man so
that they wouldn't come out to me and
like [ __ ] I don't want to [ __ ] your
gross ass boyfriend who lives in butt
[ __ ] America like right I didn't come
here to [ __ ] him came here to like make
people laugh but it's like you get some
hayden
[ __ ] on the road yeah we've done
shows where I've even seen women who are
in the audience where they already as
soon as she walks on stage oh yeah they
have checked out yeah totally no no I'm
just - I'm finished [ __ ] I love myself
and like I've noticed if someone hates
themselves they usually hate me ah yeah
yeah yeah you'll see it physically on
their face yeah like their face will
sour and pucker and she's especially
when she's doing well or if a man that
they're with or menu yeah laughing we're
into it yeah I've seen this oh yeah Wow
guys have a favorite set you've done
recently and why it was your favorite I
did a set somewhere weird in the valley
of Los Angeles and it was for a group of
AAA folks oh wow a comedy show and it's
all people who are recovering drug
addicts and alcoholics and I went up and
I did 35 minutes in front of them and I
was very nervous about it because I was
like I smoked all of the weed so I went
yeah and I did 30 minutes in front these
people they told stories I did my act I
did a bunch of stuff I took a bunch of
weird little side roads I had so much
fun and these people ate it up yeah and
there was zero judgment and it was such
a mixed bag like I went in there and
there was guys in there that looked like
they'd worked at every truck stop it
yeah yeah you know I mean there's women
in there that I was just like how many
children don't you have anymore just all
kinds of different people and I was like
these people gonna like me they're all
largely white a largely older and I
ended up having said of thee I just such
like this God's great I think probably
this corporate gig for a bunch of Indian
people oh well to be really honest like
I wasn't looking forward to it because
Indian crowds can be really hit or miss
like if they're super conservative yeah
I'm super triggering for them like they
hate me anyways I do it it's like a
bunch of professionals like mid-range
like I would say like 30s to 50s and
then this like I would say like probably
like older woman came up to me and she
said something like that really moved me
she was like it's so nice to see a
female Indian role model and I like
almost started tearing up in the best
way
yeah it was so sweet yeah I mean when I
would open for Felipe a lot of like
older Latinos I mean all lesbians but
the older ones would always just be like
we're so proud of you and I'm like oh my
god my own mother doesn't say that to me
I'm the same thing when I opened Felipe
as well yeah like all of the women in
the way that they say it
they're so relieved yeah and they all
leave and they're like talking [ __ ] to
their partners yeah they're always the
men are always like cool things it's
always so funny like when I do like
dirty sex joke yeah it's always the
Indian aunties that like are screaming
like I don't know if they're like not
getting laid at home so like when they
use jokes they go nuts amazing well
that's great that's perfect that brings
us to our next topic
I found this Twitter thread and it's
this woman with this like uterus print
shirt and she's just giving all this sex
advice she also has a [ __ ] puppet yeah
head of the clitoris is located just
under the hood okay clitoral hood and
you can stimulate the [ __ ] directly that
way okay the g-spot
is the portion where the clitoris on the
inside okay rattles the vagina if you go
on a heterosexual hookup you have an
eleven percent chance of orgasming if
you want to last pee in a cup you have a
ninety three percent chance of bullet
women orgasm a guy's crazy
the only difference is lack of penis
they're focusing exclusively on the
Clint first of all this 11 percent
number two the lady in the uterus dress
like what is the population that you
pulled one thing about sexual health
studies that I think people do not
realize is that most of the studies done
are on heterosexual white middle-class
couples number two middle-class couples
that's generally the population that's
studied so yeah maybe it sucks to be
like I don't know like a white couple in
Middle America
percent of them aren't but the rest of
us are doing great I mean you know so
you're saying your study needs to be
done yeah hell yeah
to be more studies for sure like that
tone very passionate there needs to be
better research before people go around
saying stuff like this that then causes
a lot of distress in the community I was
fascinated when she landed on the fact
that only 11 percent of women experience
orgasm when they're having heterosexual
sex oh man and woman and which my
question to both of you ladies how
important is having an orgasm to you
every time you have sex
muy importante por moi for me it's not
as important every single time but
because I view sex as a holistic
experience that's not like tied
intrinsically to an end goal of of
coming so I would like to recognize that
that is probably a much healthier way I
look at it like I just want ya like I
think that's actually like a really
healthy way of looking at central
intimacy but when I masturbate 100 my
vibrator can do things that a man cannot
do and so I'm like well if my vibe or
you can do this thing that a man can't
do then I'm fine with that and if a man
I mean I mean I thought dudes for the
dick like that also best part of the man
it's a big rate truly no question but
that's me like it is it is me you know I
don't know what cochina likes like you
know I don't even know she likes men I'm
so learning that [ __ ] too but it was
interesting hearing women debate whether
they like to orgasm every single time
because as we all know I would say what
98% of men are coming in orgasming every
single goddamn time when they're [ __ ]
a [ __ ] well are they
I mean 50% of men like above the age of
40 have erectile dysfunctions so they
may actually not be I mean as well I was
really fascinated by the the discourse
that this kind of sparked because so
many and it was a lot of black and brown
women because that's who I follow and
they were just like losing their [ __ ]
but then I think a lot of women are
scared to admit what Lydia is just
saying right now which as you said
very normal and healthy and I think just
young people in general you learn your
cues from porn you learn your cues from
music right and your cues from your
friends and you start modeling and
emulating maybe these behaviors that you
feel like are acceptable within where
you are and we've just gotten to a point
where it's okay to have an alternative
lifestyle you write like oh I'm bisexual
or not you know what I mean to play on
your gender I think there's still a huge
stigma for young men who are saying hey
I'm bisexual
yeah as opposed to women yeah and I
think the porn comment is is really
pertinent especially in terms of people
understanding what maybe even a normal
body is supposed to look like like when
men are using porn to understand sex for
the first time they actually may have
trouble when they actually are with a
real woman who's not a porn star shits
and all blown out yeah it's recognizing
oh this is what a normal body looks like
yeah so I think there's a lot of stuff
that can especially young minds yeah
they're using that as their initial
experiences to sex I was thinking about
when you're talking about you know this
is a young brown woman who's having
access to this information and she's
being encouraged to the stick her hand
in there and kind of figure it out yeah
kind of access to that yeah but like
everybody is different yeah well right
right right yeah that's one of the
problems I have to is like I always hear
the jiseop bot being described in that
same way
[ __ ] that's not where my [ __ ] is that
that's not how it works a lot of digging
around in there yeah and then some helps
somebody else digging around in there
they'll be like Oh children's book
called you should dig around in there
[Music]
like the back comes out part of
empowerment is learning what is unique
to your body absolutely it's so
important woman I think that's a
fundamental difference between why men
you know theoretically come 100 percent
yeah I'm and women theoretically come 11
percent of the time is it also goes back
to how men and women ask and lead a man
the very first time he has sex with a
woman to tell her exactly or show her
yeah let's let's hope it's with consent
right right I mean that doesn't always
happen so it depends on where you're at
but I think ladies it's also part of our
responsibility to direct traffic oh yeah
say what you want say what you
watch show him exactly where it is
because he doesn't know how to get there
yeah it's not his fault yeah bodies are
confusing you want him to [ __ ] you just
like he [ __ ] some other [ __ ] I don't
want that either
I think it's weirder than a guy that
like starts you could tell is he trying
to mean his routine and he pulls out his
routine on you and you're like I don't
know who the [ __ ] you were [ __ ]
before this but this ain't for me
exactly that is the most uncomfortable
conversation to have with someone it's
also the most liberating because that's
what you know in that moment whether or
not you're it's gonna work with that
person yeah yes if you're able to smack
them in their eyes light up and they're
like yes [ __ ] please tell me or if
they're like but this is more yeah it
pump twice and then you turn over and
then we pretend like it's new just
pretend we're pretending yeah it's how
exactly trust my help okay guys so be
yeah sure sure it's fake sir what do you
want me to say all right now that that's
all covered we're gonna jump into some
questions that have been submitted by my
followers on social media so the first
question is what's the best piece of
advice you've received from a relative a
relative I feel like most of my
relatives aid don't understand what I'm
doing
yeah RBR were weren't very supportive at
a time when I needed advice totally so I
mean maybe that's part of why this
question was brought up is maybe they're
looking for support from their family
and they're not finding it or seeing it
and they're you know because people have
expectations from their family so I
completely agree yeah I have actually
gone the best advice from like younger
cousins they're way more understanding
than like the older seniors yeah and
there's see what support what's the best
advice you've got from when in young
well I was I was going through a breakup
he just basically explained to me that
this person that had broken my heart
like wasn't the right person for me yeah
and like gave me all the examples in the
story about like why this like wasn't a
loving kind person for me yeah and he
was like exactly what I needed to hear
he's like probably less than 20 he's oh
wow like 17 18 like pretty young guy and
he just was like
so honest about it it was really
interesting that's sweet yeah that's oh
no I feel like you and I are in similar
situations where I think the best advice
isn't necessarily overt advice which was
me just getting comfortable with knowing
that my family can't necessarily provide
me the level of advice that I'm looking
for or that made other people get from
their family yeah that's okay it's not
always the exact perfect thing that I
want my mom to say but she will look at
me and she will be like as long as
you're happy I love you I believe in you
yeah it's not groundbreaking it's not
the most original advice but I know that
there's truth there and I know that
that's the best she can say because she
doesn't understand what I'm doing my dad
is no longer with us he was probably the
only other person that gave me real
advice and his advice is always very
non-sequitur and like mm-hmm
just kind of like well welcome do what
you want you know what I mean like
gnostic dad nothing crazy but it was
just accepting the fact that like I'm
not going to get profound advice but I
will get profound love if I'm open to
receiving dude once again a very healthy
mature and my response like you are
amazing like seriously and one thing
that my dad I mean he didn't really he
was not supportive of my career it took
him a long time and actually I didn't
even know until the day of his funeral
that he supported me until like all the
hits like clients would come up to me
and be like your dad was so proud of you
and I was like what have been nice to
hear from him I always loved what he
would say cuz I there was a long time
where I would like go back and forth
from Modesto to drive down here to LA
and when I would leave for the trip he
would always be like be careful in
Hollywood you can't really trust those
people you never know who you can't
trust any of them and I would always be
like that's crazy and then he was right
I actually miss him just kind of like
giving me that like little warning
before I even left the house so that was
always like one of those things that it
has stayed with me more as now that he's
gone and I hear it and it's true like
you I can't trust people out here oh
it's weird alright last question what's
the difference between a friend and a
potential lover this person goes on to
say like a dope person who's cute and
you spend time with so where does the
line go between I enjoy your beautiful
company but I don't want
date why not I don't know it's a feeling
first of all learn how to write a
question difference between a friend and
a potential lover I think that I well if
I'm understanding this question
correctly I think the physical component
is the difference between a friend and a
potential lover cuz you don't [ __ ] your
friend right I mean you could [ __ ] your
friend but like they're not just a
regular friend than if you're [ __ ]
them they're a potential lover
right right right so to me it's the
physical aspect but I don't know what do
you think first of all [ __ ] you need to
stop being afraid of commitment
yeah you need to put out there and
decide what the [ __ ] you want yeah lover
or do you want a friend [ __ ] because it
sounds like you don't know what the [ __ ]
you want alright what I think you should
do is stop wondering about your friends
and your potential lovers and love you
to himself
alright there over the [ __ ] you are and
what the [ __ ] you want and then you
won't have these dumbass questions but
to go back to what you were saying if
you want to [ __ ] somebody that's a
potential lover if you want to have
brunch with someone that's a friend in
rocket science is very very easy in your
[ __ ] wet do your nipples get hard yes
you want to [ __ ] them
yeah I think that I think the question
that this person is really asking is do
they want to ruin their friendship with
someone that they admire don't do it for
what find someone else that you don't
respect it [ __ ] them but don't do it I
mean sometimes it's good to ruin a
friendship with someone well it's good
to take the rice great like I mean I
think that's what life is that I agree
you know I definitely had male friends
who I thought we were just friends there
was no potential love stuff there and
then they made a move and my polite
decline made them uncomfortable and it
was like oh this was determining whether
we were gonna stay friends right that
makes more clear the way that you just
said that it's like well then ruin a
friendship yeah you weren't really
friends with that person yeah I've
always been someone you wanted to
potentially love like if you've had
friends for a long time and then one day
you wake up and decide you want to [ __ ]
them like I could also see that being
like oh [ __ ] like I just realized this
person is everything and I've been
ignoring this yeah I would possibly be
worth it as well right okay I'm gonna
change this dynamic but I need to change
this dynamic otherwise I can't continue
to be in a friendship right yeah those
situations yes yeah but otherwise find
new friends or [ __ ] other people that's
what this show is about we are here
for you and to make your life better my
name is Marcel Erik well thank you too
Lydia Popovich and Priyanka Wally thank
you and to cochina you guys thanks have
a good one peace
ciao
[Music]